- From this moment,
every Barbadian becomes
the living embodiment
of the new republic.
Whether fair or foul winds come our way,
Vessel Republic Barbados has set sail
on her maiden voyage.
(lively music)
- From the darkest days of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery,
which forever stains our history,
the people of this
island forged their path
with extraordinary fortitude.
- [Observer] And the
first look, there she is.
(crowd cheering)
- May you continue to shine like a diamond
and bring honor to your nation
by your words, by your actions
and to do credit wherever you shall go.
- Faithful and be a true
allegiance to Barbados
according to law, so help me God.
We are Barbadians,
we the people must give
Republic Barbados its spirit
and its substance.
We must shape its future.
We are each other's and
our nation's keepers.
We, the people, are Barbados.
(people clapping)
(lively music)